o psol jamais um vídeo e hoje vou
ensinar como fazer uma espada do papel
que dispara elásticos as minhas palavras
vão disparar 3 elásticos mas se vocês
quiserem ter 45 também da e por fazer
este projeto precisava de folha de papel
ou usar folhas com tamanho a4 e a3
agora se vocês não tiverem folhas com o
tamanho a3 nos preocupa que vocês podem
circular duas folhas com o tamanho a4
que vão ter uma folha com o tamanho a3
a primeira coisa que você tem que fazer
e 4 rifas e para isso é bastante simples
vocês têm como sair largo foi o papel de
um canto em direção ao outro canto
e é muito importante que vocês façam
isso moda cortado e solar bem a rifa
depois de colocarem é fita no maio
em seguida vamos usar uma das reféns
para fazer em 10 tubos deles e vejam
como está disposto a folha ou seja vocês
vão ir lá naquela parte que é mais
estreita e assim vou enrolar mais vezes
que tudo vai ficar mais forte e é muito
importante que vocês é justo em outubro
eu tenha ficado assim seu primeiro de um
lado e do outro
no final vocês têm que aprender com fita
como estão a ver a equipe ovelha
é preciso fazer mais duas infantis mas
estas não ser com folhas com tamanho a3
e como eu disse no início ou seja não
tiverem artrite podem sentar duas folhas
com o tamanho a4
depois vocês vão precisar juntar as duas
rifas grande fizeram anteriormente
utilizando fita é muito importante que
elas fiquem banco linhas uma contra a
outra
se vocês quiserem e podem pôr cola no
maio e depois por fita
esta parte é mais pela estrutura ou seja
vai ficar dentro da espada e quanto mais
resistente está para ficar mais
resistente a vossa espada vai ficar
também para fazer empreendedora da arma
eu vou usar quatro tubos com 15
centímetros
mas se vocês quiserem ter uma
empunhadura maior é só aumentar esse
número e para fix aos eu vou usar cola
quente mas se vocês quiserem podem usar
só fita que também está
para fazer a lâmina da espada como
cidade uma folha com o tamanho a3 dólar
el mayo depois dobre outra vez para o
maio mas deixa uma pequena distância
entre a linha do maio ea borda da folha
com vocês dobraram para dentro
mais ou menos aí três milímetros
depois da obra em paulinha do maior a
mesma linha do maio
depois tem que dobrar também paulinha do
maio mas isto é só para criar a marcação
da lâmina da espada ou seja rodar aquele
aspecto volumoso da lâmina
nesta parte é muito importante que vocês
usem bastante colin quinn
quanto mais utilizar e mais tempo vai
ficar a vossa espada especial atenção no
parto em que vai fechar a lâmina ponham
lá mais escola porque ali que vão ser
feitos os cortes para encaixar os
elásticos
então quanto mais resistente em casa que
é o quarto mais elástico vocês vão
colocar mais tarde
por questão de segurança e vocês têm que
abandonar esta parte aqui do bico desta
maneira
dobrinhas quatro rifles que vocês
fizeram maio e depois corta enm com oito
centímetros como vocês estão vendo aqui
no rio lockyer dentro dos tubos de 16
centímetros e tem que fazer isso por
dois lados e depois tem que ter um pouco
de cola brasil só tem a opinião dele foi
para fora por cada lado
porém cola e depois de metem para dentro
é muito importante entender a cola
porque senão depois mais para frente
isso vai sair pois não vai conseguir
agora vocês têm que fazer um furo no
meio da marina é mais ou menos dois
centímetros a empunhadura e para isso
vou usar a minha arte fica mas se vocês
não tiverem podem usar sua broca e
irlanda assim como ao que vão conseguir
fazer o buraco no mesmo a cair o papel
não é assim tão resistente
vou precisar usar mais uma folha com o
tamanho a3 e com ela vamos fazer uma
faixa bastante resistente e primeiro
vocês vão abrir em law maio
quem tem baile pois tempo do braga outra
vez ao maio e outra vez ao maio
e pra finalizar é só vocês aprenderem
com fita é que ela parte da abertura com
fita ou então com cola mas é mais fácil
com fita porque ele tem várias camadas
então refis falar bastante
agora muita atenção nesta para vocês têm
que dobraram a faixa ao maio vinca ela
by e tem encaixado pois a volta da
lâmina e dobre-a um ângulo mais ou menos
95 100 graus não é 90 é baixo dos 90
retirem dobra dos dois lados de modo que
uma parte fixa proposta à outra parte
fica por baixo e para finalizar é só
colar com vocês vão ver no vídeo
para incluí-las tempo depois saiu mais
facilmente vocês têm que cortar um
ângulo mais ou menos assim a 45% ver
aqui e depois tem que fazer um furo mas
muita atenção este furo tem que ser
exatamente onde eu vou fazê lo cair
então estejam bem evidente
e chegamos a parte mais delicada que
fazer estes cortes aqui e vou fazer 39
vocês quiserem podem fazer mais
é muito importante que utilizei um x-ato
com lâmina nova
eu usei uma lâmina antiga e como vocês
podem ver os cortes não ficaram assim
tão perfeitinhas isso vocês forem
crianças peçam ajuda um adulto e na hora
não ser customizado
se vocês quiserem que vocês para
agüentar por muito tempo eu recomendo
que vocês ponham super cola nas partes
onde vocês cortaram e é só colocar o
sifão colo de chaska e depois está
pronta a utilizar e uma coisa na hora de
vocês colocaram os elásticos tem que
começar a colocar o elástico que fica
mais indicado
depois eu fiquei no maio e depois fica
mais mais - indicado é isso aí foi só de
parar e claro tem que usar óculos de
proteção e não podem disparar contra
ninguém
espero que vocês tenham gostado desse
projeto eu tentei trazer de volta as
armas do papel as coisas feitas com
papel é porque vocês têm nada pedir
mesmo muito nos comentários
e isso eu vou tentar fazer sempre assim
um modo mais tempo lista por seu filho é
muito complicado você exclamou ao fazer
estava muito mesmo muito mais bonita mas
aí que ficar bastante complicado pra
vocês fazer é isso aí você tiver alguma
sugestão é só deixar nos comentários